kubernetes makes it possible to
containerize applications and simplifies
deployment to production bogden stachook
will teach you everything you need to
know to get started with kubernetes
welcome to the kubernetes for beginners
kubernetes is de facto standard for
deployment of the containerized
applications into production
kubernetes is open source and therefore
it is free for use
let me first introduce myself before we
will start this course my name is
bogdansta shook and i've been using
docker and kubernetes multiple years on
practice and i deployed real world
applications into production using
kubernetes
also i'm teaching online and on my
personal website statute.com you could
find all courses which i teach
now let's get started with kubernetes
for beginners
and i would like to start with course
plan so what is included in this course
we will start by talking about
terminology and the key features of the
kubernetes and you'll learn what is
kubernetes cluster what is node and what
a spot and what kubernetes essentially
does
afterwards we will immediately dive into
the practice and we will build small
kubernetes cluster locally on our
computers and afterwards using such
cluster we will create and scale
different deployments
also we will build custom docker image
push it to docker hub and afterwards
create kubernetes deployment based on
this customly built docker image
other than that we will also create
services and deployments in kubernetes
using yaml configuration files
also we will connect different
deployments together because it's very
common situation when you have to
connect different applications together
over their network and kubernetes allows
of course to do that
and also finally we will change
container runtime from the docker to
crio because kubernetes is not bound to
docker it also supports other container
runtimes like crio and container d
and you could use kubernetes absolutely
without docker
one single prerequisite for this course
is your familiarity with docker i assume
that you know what is docker container
and how to create different containers
all right so let's get started with this
course and i would like to start with
definition
kubernetes is container orchestration
system
using docker you could of course create
container on any computer
but of course if you want to create
multiple containers on different
computers on different servers you could
get into the troubles
kubernetes allows you to create
containers on different servers either
physical or virtual and all of that is
done automatically without your
intervention you just tell kubernetes
how many containers you would like to
create based on a specific image
kubernetes is relatively long word and
it consists of 10 different letters but
it professionals and software developers
are relatively lazy people and they
don't like to type much that's why such
a long word is usually shortened just to
three characters but how is it done
let's have a look at this word between k
and s there are actually eight different
letters so number eight that's why
long word kubernetes could be shortened
just to three characters k
eight s so eight represents simply
quantity of the letters between starting
and ending letter simple as that
knowing this very simple trick we could
go on and now let me explain to you
what kubernetes takes care of so
kubernetes takes care of automatic
deployment of the containerized
applications across different servers
and those servers could be either bare
metal or physical servers or virtual
servers virtual servers option is of
course more common nowadays and almost
no one uses no bare metal servers
so kubernetes allows you to perform
automated deployments across different
servers that could be located even in
different parts of the world
other than that kubernetes also takes
care of distribution of the load across
those multiple servers
and this allows you to use your
resources efficiently and avoid
underutilization or over utilization of
the resources
also kubernetes takes care of the auto
scaling of the deployed applications in
case you need to increase for example
quantity of the containers which have to
be created on different servers
and all of that done automatically you
just tell when you want to scale up or
down
also kubernetes takes care of the
monitoring and health check of the
containers
and in case some containers fail for
some reasons kubernetes could
automatically replace failed containers
and all of that done without your
intervention
as i just told you kubernetes deploys
containerized applications and therefore
it has to use specific container run
time
and docker is just one of the possible
options
kubernetes nowadays supports such
container runtimes
docker crio and container d
and such container runtime for example
as docker or crio must be running on
each of the servers which are included
in the kubernetes cluster
and
main outcome here is that kubernetes
could be utilized even without docker at
all it supports other container runtimes
like crio and container d and at the end
of this course i'll demonstrate to you
how to change container time and move
from docker for example to crio
so now let's get started with
terminology and architecture of
kubernetes
and let's start with pod
pod is the smallest unit in the
kubernetes world
in docker world container is smallest
unit in kubernetes port is the smallest
possible unit
and containers are created inside of the
pot so what anatomy is following
inside of the pot there could be
containers either one or even several
containers
also there are shared volumes
and
shared network resources for example
shared ip address
this means that all containers inside of
the same port
share volumes and share ip address
and you must keep that in mind if you
want to create multiple containers
inside of the same pot
most common scenario of course is to
have just single container per pot but
sometimes when containers have to be
tightened together and they heavily
depend on each other and they could
exist in the same name space it is
possible to create several containers in
the same pot
but again
single container per port is the most
common use case
also please keep in mind that each port
must be located on the same server it is
not possible to spread
containers from one pot across different
servers in the kubernetes cluster
one port one server
so let's now have a look at the
kubernetes cluster what is that
kubernetes cluster consists of nodes
node is actually server either bare
metal server or virtual server
and you could include multiple such
servers into the kubernetes cluster and
they could be located in different data
centers in different parts of the world
but usually nodes which belong to the
same kubernetes cluster are located
close to each other in order to
perform all jobs more efficiently
inside of the node there are pods
port is again the smallest possible unit
in the kubernetes
and inside of each port there are
containers usually single container per
pot
and such pods are created on different
nodes
and all of that is done automatically
for you kubernetes does this job
but of course your job is to create such
nodes and create cluster based on those
nodes
nodes will not automatically form
cluster without your intervention
but after such initial configuration
everything will be automated and
kubernetes will automatically deploy
ports on different nodes
but how those nodes actually communicate
with each other and how are they managed
in kubernetes cluster there is
master node
and other nodes in the cluster are
called worker nodes
and masternode actually manages worker
nodes
and it's master node's job to distribute
for example load across other worker
nodes
and all ports which are related to your
applications are deployed on worker
nodes
masternode runs only system ports which
are responsible for actual work of the
kubernetes cluster in general
we could also say that master node in
the kubernetes cluster is actually
control plane and it does not run your
client applications
so
which services
actually run on different nodes
let's have a look at this diagram
there are such services as cubelet cube
proxy and container runtime
and those services
are present on each node in the
kubernetes cluster
you already know what is the container
runtime container runtime runs actual
containers inside of each node
and there are such container runtimes as
docker crio or container d
there is also such service as cubelet
and such service on each worker node
communicates with api server service on
the master node
api server service is the main point of
communication between different nodes in
the kubernetes world
cube proxy which is present on each node
as well is responsible for network
communication inside of each node and
between nodes
also there are other services which are
present on masternode and they are
scheduler and such service is
responsible for planning and
distribution of the load between
different nodes in the cluster
also there is cube controller manager
and it is single point which controls
everything actually in the kubernetes
cluster and it controls actually what
happens on each of the nodes in the
cluster
also there is cloud controller manager
and its job is interaction with cloud
service provider where you actually run
your kubernetes cluster because usually
you don't create
such clusters yourself using just your
own servers instead you could very
easily rent a kubernetes cluster from
one of the cloud providers which
actually perform almost automated
creation of all nodes and the
connections between such nodes
and for that you have to run cloud
controller manager service on the master
node
also for example if you want to
create the deployment of your
application inside of the kubernetes
cluster which will be opened to outside
world and allow connections from outside
you could create also load balancer ip
addresses and those load balancers ip
addresses are usually provided by
specific cloud providers
also on masternode there is such service
as etcd and this is a service which
actually stores all logs related to
operation of entire kubernetes cluster
and such logs are stored there as key
value pairs
also there are other services which are
running on masternode for example dns
service which is responsible for names
resolution in entire kubernetes cluster
and for instance using a dns service you
could connect to specific deployment by
the name of the corresponding deployment
service and in such a way you could
connect different deployments with each
other
that are different services which are
running on different nodes in the
kubernetes cluster and the main service
on the master node is api server
and by the way using this api server
service you could actually manage entire
kubernetes cluster
how is it done
it is done by using cube ctl or
cubecontrol
and cubecontrol is separate command line
tool which allows you to connect to
specific kubernetes cluster and manage
it remotely
and
cube ctl could be running even on your
local computer and using such cube ctl
tool you could manage remote kubernetes
cluster
and using such tool you actually connect
using rest api to api server service on
the master node and such communication
happens over https
by the way other nodes in the cluster i
mean worker nodes communicate with
master node in the same fashion
it means that using such a cubectl tool
you could manage any remote kubernetes
cluster that's it for kubernetes
architecture overview and now you know
that the kubernetes cluster consists of
the nodes and the one of the nodes is
master node and it manages other nodes
which are called worker nodes
on each node there are pods and the
ports are created automatically by
kubernetes and inside of the port there
are containers usually just single
container per port
also please keep in mind that all
containers inside of the port share
name spaces of that port
like volumes or network ip address
also ports are smallest units in
kubernetes and the ports could be
created that could be removed could be
moved from one node to another this
happens automatically without your
intervention
but you have to design your application
with this in mind ports could be deleted
on any moment of time
also there are different services which
are running on different nodes for
example api server service is central
point of communication between
masternode and other worker nodes and
also using such api server service you
actually could manage actual kubernetes
cluster using cube ctl tool which has to
be installed for example on your
computer if you perform management from
your computer
all right
i don't want to dive deeper into the
details of the kubernetes because this
is very complicated tool and i want to
focus more on practical tasks instead
that's why now after such overview we
will dive together with you into the
practice and perform different practical
tasks together for example we will
create deployments services scale
deployments
create custom docker image and create
the deployment based on that image and
so on
in order to perform all practical tasks
together with me you have to install
some programs on your computer
and now let me talk about required
software and first we have to create
actual kubernetes cluster where we will
create different deployments
of course you could create cluster using
services from one of the cloud providers
like amazon web services or google cloud
but you have to pay for such service
if you want free solution you could
create cluster locally on your computer
and for that there is such tool as mini
cube
and such tool will essentially create
just a single node cluster and this node
will be both worker node and master node
but for test deployments and
as a playground it works pretty nice and
all of that is free and will be running
on your local computer
in order to run mini cube successfully
you have to utilize virtual machine or
container manager
and there are following virtual machine
or container managers which are
supported virtualbox
vmware
docker
hyper id
or parallels there are also other
options available but you have to
utilize one of such options in order to
actually create the virtual node which
will run all posts in your kubernetes
cluster
i suggest you to go ahead with hyper-v
if you are windows user
and if you are mac os user you could go
ahead with virtualbox it is free and
open source or you could utilize vmware
or parallels
by the way there is also an option to
run mini cube
as a container inside of the docker
of course if you have docker already
installed on your computer you could
utilize it in order to create kubernetes
cluster using mini cube and essentially
it will create a separate docker
container and inside of that container
all posts will be created but i
personally don't recommend to you to go
ahead with docker option because there
was some limitations for example i was
not able to change a container runtime
inside of the docker container to cri or
or container d
and therefore i recommend to you to go
ahead with other options which i
mentioned here by the way hyper v is
available on windows computers out of
the box and you could utilize it as
virtual machine manager for running mini
cube node to summarize using mini cube
you will create single node kubernetes
cluster but as i mentioned before you
have to use specific tool in order to
manage this cluster and this tool is
called cubectl
by the way cubectl is included in
minicube but
if you want to use such included version
you have to enter minicube cubectl
commands it is not convenient therefore
i recommend to you to install cubectl
separately and using separate
installation you will be able of course
to manage other kubernetes clusters
which are located for example at amazon
web services
so cubectl is also one of the programs
which you have to install on your
computer
certainly i'll explain to you how to
install minicube and cubectl
other than that we will also do some
coding in this practical course and for
that you have to use one of the code
editors and i recommend to you to
install visual studio code it is open
source and free for use and if you have
not yet installed it please go ahead and
install it also it has many different
extensions and one of them is kubernetes
extension and using such extension you
could very fast create for instance yaml
configuration files for your deployments
and services in kubernetes
that's all what you need for this course
mini cube cube ctl and visual studio
code
now let's get started with practical
part and i hope you'll enjoy this course
and we will start with the installation
of the mini cube and cube ctl
alright guys now let's get started with
practical part of the course and we will
start by installing mini cube along with
cube ctl
but first i would like to ask you to
navigate to kubernetes.io
this is the main site dedicated to
kubernetes in general and it has
all documentation related to
configuration of the mini cube clusters
creation of deployments etc
please click here on documentation
and here in the left section go to
getting started
and here you could read how you could
create learning environment
along with that you could also find
information how to create production
environment but we are interested to
know in creation of the local kubernetes
cluster
and for that we will utilize mini cube
and also we will install cube ctl that's
why please click here on this hyperlink
install tools and you'll find
instructions how to install cubectl on
different operating systems
please choose yours i'll choose mac os
here
and
if you're mac os user you could very
easily install cubectl using homebrew
let me demonstrate you how to do that
let me click on this option
run the installation command brew
install cube ctl let me copy this
command and open up terminal i'm using
item 2 on mac and paste this command
here let's go ahead and install cubectl
downloading package
and cubectl was installed let me check
version of the cubectl for that i could
utilize this command cubectl version
client
let me enter it here
and i see that the cubectl was installed
successfully and here is client version
major one and minor 22 and here is
actually exact version which was
installed all right if you're a windows
user i recommend to you to install
cube cdl using package manager you could
go to install and setup cube ctl on
windows and here choose option install
on windows using chocolaty or scoop
click on this option and here you'll
find instructions how to install
different packages using chocolaty
package manager or scoop command line
installer i recommend to you to install
chocolaty package manager in order to do
that please open up this link here
and find instructions how to install
this package manager for windows
using the same package manager you could
very easily install mini cube as well so
please go ahead and install this package
manager and afterwards follow those
instructions on how to install cubectl
on windows
use just single command this one and
afterwards verify that cubectl is
available using this command
all right after this i assume that
cubectl is already available on your
computers and now let's go ahead and
install minicube go back to getting
started page and here scroll down to
learning environment and click on
hyperlink install tools this one
you'll find again that you have to
install cubectl that's what we just did
together and if you scroll down you'll
find options which you could utilize in
order to create local kubernetes cluster
for learning and testing purposes
nowadays there are such tools as kind
and it allows you to create kubernetes
cluster locally on your computer but it
requires docker
also there is mini cube and cube adam
we will utilize mini cube throughout
this course that's why let's get started
with installation of the mini cube it
does not require docker but it does
require one of the virtual machine
managers like hyper-v parallels or if
you want you could also utilize docker
please navigate to this link mini cube
you could simply enter mini cube in the
google search bar and click on the first
result in the output and here you'll
find documentation how to get started
with minicube
please click on this link get started
and here you could read about minicube
and it will basically create the
kubernetes cluster locally on your
computer and it will contain just a
single node which will act both as
master node and worker node
and all what you need in order to create
such a cluster is just single command
mini cube start simple as that
but in order to successfully create a
mini cube cluster you have to install
one of the container or virtual machine
managers such as docker hyperkit hyper v
parallels and so on
i told you before that if you are
windows user i recommend to you to
utilize hyper v because it is available
on windows out of the box
if you are mac user i recommend to you
to go ahead either with
virtualbox option or parallels or vmware
fusion virtualbox is free for use
therefore if you don't want to pay
anything for virtual machine manager i
recommend you to go ahead with this
option
also it is possible to create mini cube
cluster inside of the container docker
container and for that you could just
install docker but i personally don't
recommend to you to go ahead with this
option because there are some
limitations in running such a cluster
inside of the docker container
alright here below you could find out
how to install mini cube on different
operating systems linux mac os and
windows
if you are windows user you could
similarly as with cubectl utilize
chocolaty please select this option and
enter just single command choco install
mini cube simple as that and you'll get
mini cube installed on windows computer
but i'm using mac os that's why i'll
select this option and select homebrew
and in order to install mini cube using
brew i could simply enter just one
command brew install mini cube
let me go ahead and install it using
brew let's go back to terminal and here
paste command brew install mini cube
let's wait a bit until it is installed
all right mini cube was installed and
now i could verify its version mini cube
version
here is version in my case and you could
also enter mini cube help command in
order to find the list of all available
commands in minicube and if you scroll
up you'll find out how to start local
kubernetes cluster get status of the
local kubernetes cluster stop cluster
delete and open dashboard
also you could to pause and unpause
kubernetes cluster
great
now let's create actual cluster i assume
that now you have also installed mini
cube and cube ctl those tools are two
separate tools that's why they are
available as two separate commands mini
cube and
cube ctl
and now let's go ahead and create
kubernetes cluster for that please
utilize command mini cube
start but first let's enter mini cube
status in order to check current status
of the cluster mini cube status
here i see that profile mini cube not
found run mini q profile list to view
all profiles and also i see that in
order to start cluster i have to run
mini cube start command that's what we
are about to do right now
let's create cluster mini cube start
and here i would like to ask you to
start
mini cube cluster with option and this
option will be driver and you should
write it with two dashes dash dash
driver
and here will be equal sign and after it
you have to specify virtual machine or
container manager which you would
utilize in order to create mini cube
cluster
i mentioned before that if you are
windows user i recommend to you to use
hyper v
therefore if you are on windows simply
enter here hyper v like that all lower
case without dash
dash dash driver equal assign hyper-v
if you are mac os user you could go
ahead with any of those options
virtualbox parallels or vmware fusion
i will utilize virtualbox if you don't
have your toolbox please go ahead and
install it
enter here your toolbox
and click on the first link here
your toolbox is free and here is link
where you could download virtualbox
so if you don't have your toolbox and if
you're a macos user please go ahead and
download virtualbox
great i already have your toolbox
installed that's why i will simply
specify it as the value for the driver
option here
so i will type virtual
box
let's go ahead and create mini cube
cluster inside of the virtualbox virtual
machine in my case
creating virtualbox virtual machine
quantity of cpus memory and disk
it will take a while let me wait a bit
virtual machine was created and now i
see message preparing kubernetes
on docker and it means that by default
we will utilize docker container runtime
for running actual containers inside of
the kubernetes cluster
here i see step generating certificates
and keys booting up control plane
and finally at the end i see done
cubectl is now configured to use
minicube cluster and that means that you
don't need to do anything in order to
connect from cubectl to actual minicube
cluster this connection was created
automatically for you during creation of
the minicube cluster also in my case i
see such a warning you have selected
virtualbox driver but there are better
options for better performance and
support consider using a different
driver hyperkit parallels or vmware
now let's actually verify status of this
kubernetes cluster and for that you
could enter command mini cube status
and you should find out that host is
running cubelet is running api server is
running and cubeconfig is configured
that's normal status of the mini cube
cluster and now we are actually able to
create deployments services etc inside
of this mini cube cluster
also i would like to mention that i
don't have docker running right now i
actually have it installed on this
computer but over here in the icons bar
i don't see docker icon it means that
now kubernetes on my local computer does
not utilize actual docker installation
on my computer
but there is a docker which is running
inside of the mini cube node
and that's what we will check right now
so as you already know each node in the
kubernetes cluster is just server either
virtual or physical in our case we have
created virtual server and you could
connect to any server by using ssh
protocol and in order to connect via ssh
we first need to find out which ip
address was assigned to kubernetes node
minicube provides command for that
simply type minicube ip and you'll see
which ip address was assigned to virtual
machine which is running our kubernetes
node which was created by minicube here
is ap address in my case simply grab
this ip address and afterwards type ssh
docker it is username which is default
username for
such a node such virtual server and
after add sign paste ap address of
minicube node and afterwards please
press enter
you will be presented with fingerprint
please go ahead and type here yes we
trust such a fingerprint
and afterwards you will be prompted for
password default password for minicube
virtual machine is tc user
please go ahead and type it here so
username is docker and password is dc
user
password was entered and now i see
welcome prompt from the minicube server
now i am inside of the kubernetes node
and first command which i would like to
ask you to enter here is docker ps
such command will list you all running
docker containers
and here a bunch of different containers
which were created inside of the
kubernetes node
and again please recap that docker is
default container runtime for kubernetes
there are other container runtimes such
as crio and container d
but here we see that there are a bunch
of different containers which were
created by docker inside of the mini
cube node
and for instance here i see such
container as cube api server cube
scheduler and so on recap that we
discussed with you different services
which are running on master nodes and
worker nodes and those services are
actually running inside of the
containers as you see right now here
also there are such containers as the
cube proxy storage provisioner or for
instance core dns
and again every container has its own
purpose
that's how you could verify which
containers were created inside of the
kubernetes node but if i enter here cube
ctl command i'll see error cube ctl
command not found because cubectl
command is not available inside of the
kubernetes node cubectl is external tool
which is used in order to manage
kubernetes cluster
that's why let's now go out of this ssh
connection connection was closed and now
let's utilize cubectl command here of
course cubectl is available locally on
our computers because we have installed
cubectl before
let's first check clusterinfo
cluster dash info
and i get following output kubernetes
control plane is running and here i see
ip address which we just saw after
entering mini cube ip command in your
case of course such ep address will be
different
and also i see that core dns service is
running as well
it means that now we are able actually
to create deployments services etc on
our kubernetes cluster but first let's
list nodes which are available in our
kubernetes cluster for that please enter
command cube ctl get
nodes
and here i see just single note because
minicube creates single node cluster
here is name of such node status is
ready and here are roles control plane
and master
recap that now inside of our mini cube
cluster this single node acts both as
master node and worker node and on
worker node kubernetes creates different
ports related to your deployments which
you deploy in kubernetes cluster
now let me check which ports are
available right now in this cluster for
that let's enter command cube ctl get
ports
and now i see output no resources found
in default namespace
let's list all namespaces which are
available now in this kubernetes cluster
for that please enter command cube ctl
get name spaces
like that and i see several namespaces
like default cube node list cube public
and cube system
namespaces are used in kubernetes in
order to group different resources and
configuration objects
and if you enter simply cube ctl get
ports you will see only ports available
inside of the default namespace here and
by the way all pods which we'll create
throughout this course will be created
in default namespace but we have not yet
created any pods so far
that's why let's try to find out which
ports are running inside of other
namespaces for instance cube system
in order to list ports in specific
namespace you have to utilize namespace
option so cubectl
dash
getpods
name space
equal sign and here enter cube system
let's go ahead and run this command and
now here in this namespace cube system i
see such pods as core dns etcd which
stores logs of entire kubernetes cluster
cube api server cube controller cube
proxy cube scheduler and storage
provisioner all those spots are system
pods which are running on this master
node
all right that's how we could find out
which ports are running right now in our
kubernetes cluster
now let's go ahead and create port
manually and for that we could utilize
command which is similar to docker run
command but with docker run command you
could create just single docker
container
here you could utilize cube ctl run
command in order to create just single
port let's do that cube ctl run here
will be named let's for instance utilize
nginx docker image which is available at
docker hub for that let's enter here
name of the port nginx and afterwards
let's add option
image
and its value will be nginx
nginx here is name of the docker image
which will be pulled automatically and
new container will be created based on
this image and this container will be
running inside of the kubernetes port
let's go ahead and see what will happen
cube ctl run nginx dash dash image equal
sign nginx and here i see output port
nginx created let's enter command cube
ctl
get put
and here i see
now single port nginx it is not yet
ready and its status is container
creating
let's enter same command again cubectl
getpods and now i see that this port is
now running it is ready and its status
is running
of course it took some time in order to
create such a port because inside of it
there was engineers container and
docker inside of the kubernetes node
was actually requested to pull nginx
image from docker hub and create
corresponding container
based on such image nginx
let's now find out the tails of this
specific port with name nginx this name
we specified manually here
for that please enter command cube ctl
describe
port and here will be name of the port
which you would like to describe get
details about
here will be nginx it is name of the
running pot
and here are many different details
related to this specific pot let me
scroll a bit up
and
here i'll find out such information as
namespace this port belongs to
and it was automatically assigned to
default namespace that's why we were
able to
see it in the list when we entered
command cubectl getpods because such
command lists all posts inside of the
default namespace
here is information about node where
such specific port was created recap
that kubernetes automatically
distributes load across all nodes worker
nodes inside of the cluster and it
selects specific node for specific port
and that's information about the node
where this particular port was created
in our single node cluster of course you
will see the same node each time when
you create any port and here is ip
address of such node
here is start time here are labels
status is running and here is ap address
which was assigned to this particular
port
172 1703
but please note that now we will not be
able to connect to this particular port
using such internal ip address of the
port
in order to be able to connect to ports
you have to create services in
kubernetes and that's what we will look
at a bit later
here below you could also find out which
containers were created inside of this
spot and there was just single container
here is id of such container here is
long id here is image which was utilized
for this particular container and that's
that image which we specified using dash
dash image option when we created new
port
here is image id and it is id of the
image from the docker hub because by
default kubernetes pulls all images from
the docker hub of course it's possible
to configure kubernetes to pull images
from other repository hosting services
but default is docker hub
all right these are details about this
particular port
and we find out that there is ip address
assigned to this port there is container
which was created inside of this port
and here are logs related to creation of
this particular port
you see that this particular port was
successfully assigned to mini cube node
here is message about pulling image
nginx from the docker hub successfully
pulled image
created container nginx and started
container nginx and it means that now
there is nginx container running inside
of the created port
again you could find the list of all
ports by entering command cube ctl
get ports
and here is single port available right
now in the default namespace
now let's quickly go back again inside
of the kubernetes mini cube node
and list again docker containers and we
will find out that now there is one more
container which was created in the nginx
spot
so using up arrow i could go back to the
ssh command which i entered before here
it is and connect to this node again
enter tc user password
and let's enter here a docker ps but now
let's filter output
by
name nginx
and now i'll find out that there are two
different containers here is first one
and heroes second one which are related
to nginx
here is the name of the first container
k8s ngnx nginx default and so on
and also there is one more container k8s
port nginx default and so on
and this second container is called
pause container here you see that inside
of the container pause executable was
actually launched when container was
created
and if docker is a container runtime in
kubernetes
there are always such pos containers
which are created for each specific port
and such post containers are created in
order to
let's say lock namespace of specific
port and we discussed before that all
containers inside of the same port
actually share namespaces
and this container which is actually
running our nginx web server
could be stopped could be recreated by
kubernetes but port remains untouched
and this second container which is
called pos container is required to keep
name space of the pot
all right that's how containers look
right now
and let's actually connect to this
container where we are running nginx
service
in order to connect to container you
could use either id this one or this
name let's connect to container by this
id please select this container not post
container and let's
enter command
docker
exec
id
here is id of the container and let's
connect this container using sha
executable now i am inside of the
container
let's check its host name
nginx
it is name of the pod actually and same
name was assigned to this container and
let's also check ip address of this
container here is such iep address 172
1703
and that's that ap address which we saw
in the details of the port
now let's try to connect web server
which is running inside of this
container where we are currently in by
using this ip address and for that we
could utilize c url command and here a
paste ap address of this particular
container recap that we are inside of
the nginx container
let's try to make connection and here i
see welcome to nginx page which was
returned by this web server
it means that nginx web server is up and
running
let's go out of this container
and now we are still inside of the
kubernetes node okay that we made ssh
connection to it and now let's exit from
this connection as well like that and
now let's enter following command cube
ctl
get pods
dash all white and with such option
you'll find also ip address of
particular port in this output and here
is the same ip address which we just saw
inside of the container
let's now try to connect to such ep
address from our computer
our computer is external relative to our
kubernetes cluster because kubernetes
node is running inside of the virtual
machine
and this ip address was assigned by
docker to particular container inside of
the node
let's try to connect to such ap address
i could utilize the same command c url
here it is available on mac
or you could simply open up web browser
and connect to this ap address and
you'll find out that you will not be
able to connect to nginx container like
that because as i told you before such
ip address is internally addressed of
the port and you are not able to connect
to such port from outside world outside
of the cluster
great that's how we created very first
port in our kubernetes cluster and we
also explored the tails of such port and
i hope that now it is clear to you what
happens when you create a port inside of
the port kubernetes creates a container
and in order to create container it has
to pull image from the docker hub and in
our example nginx image was pulled and
new container was created based on that
image
also we went inside of the container and
verified that nginx web server is now
actually running but we are not able to
connect to such port from the outside
because now it has only internal ip
address which was assigned by the docker
but of course creation of the ports
using cube ctl run command is not really
convenient because you are not able to
scale and for example increase quantity
of the pots there is just single pot
which we created using cube ctl run
command that's right now let's simply
delete created port for that there is
command cube ctl delete
next will be name of the resource we
would like to delete and it is spot and
here will be name of the port in our
example nginx because we specified such
name for the port manually when we
entered cubectl run command so let's go
ahead and delete such a port
port nginx deleted cubectl
getpods
and there are no resources found in
default namespace
and such port is simply gone
and all volumes all namespaces related
to this particular port were removed
great
you might notice that we entered cubectl
command multiple times and in my opinion
such command is relatively long and
we are able to create alias for such
command in order to save some time in
the future and we could alias cubectl
command to just a single letter k
and afterwards we will enter such
commands as k getport but now if i enter
such command i'll get the command not
found error because i have not yet
created any aliases
on linux like operating systems you
could very easily create alias by
entering command alias
next will be alias for the command then
equal sign and after equal sign in
double quotes you could write command
which you would like to alias in our
example cube ctl
if you are a windows user and if you are
using powershell
this command will not work there
if you want to get similar to mine
experience in command line i recommend
to you to install git bash in order to
install it please navigate to git
scm-com and simply download git if git
is already installed on your windows
computer you already have access to git
bash
it is another terminal if you don't have
git installed please go to windows
section here and download git for
windows here are different links to it
and after installation please open git
bash terminal instead of the powershell
so
i already have alias command available
in this terminal on my course therefore
i will be able to create such an alias
let's create alias alias was created and
now i'm able to utilize just short
version of the command k get bots
and now i see output no resources found
in default namespace
from this point on i will utilize such
short version of the cubectl command but
please notice that such alias will live
only during this session in the terminal
after a lot of the computer or when you
open up another terminal session this
alias will be gone if you would like to
create a permanent alias of course it is
possible to do in order to perform such
a task you have to edit your shell
configuration profile but i will not do
that right now it's enough to have just
temporal alias
great now let's continue as i mentioned
before it is not convenient to create
separate ports inside of the kubernetes
cluster because you are not able to
scale and increase quantity of the pots
therefore the most common way to create
multiple posts when you are able to
increase quantity of the ports decrease
quantity modify configuration etc is by
using deployments
and deployment will be responsible for
creation of the actual ports but please
notice that all ports inside of the
deployment will be the same exactly the
same but you could create multiple
copies of the same port
and distribute load across different
nodes in the kubernetes cluster that's
purpose of the deployment
now let's go ahead and create deployment
and we will utilize same image which we
utilized before it is nginx image
and also afterwards we will increase
quantity of the ports in this deployment
and also we will create a service for
this deployment in order to be able to
connect to our deployment from external
world let's go ahead and create such
deployment and for that we will utilize
command cubectl create deployment we
already aliased the cubectl command
that's why i will enter k
create
deployment
and next will be name of the deployment
let's name it nginx
and afterwards let's specify also image
similarly as we did in
cubectl run command and here after equal
sign will be name of the image we would
like to utilize for this deployment and
let's enter here nginx
in order to avoid any confusion let's
modify name of this deployment and let's
name it for instance nginx dash
deployment like that let's go ahead and
create this deployment
deployment was created let's enter
command k get deployments
here is single deployment it is ready
and up to date and let's enter k get
pots
and now i see that there is no single
port which is managed by this particular
deployment
and such a port was created
automatically after we created such
deployment
and now this spot is managed by this
deployment
there is just single port at the moment
and of course it is possible to scale
quantity of the pots and increase
quantity of the pots for instance to 3 5
and so on
but first before doing that let's read
details about size deployment and for
that let's enter command k describe
deployment
and here will be name of the deployment
nginx deployment
here are details of created deployment
let's scroll a bit up
and here at the beginning of the output
i see name of the deployment nginx
deployment that's that name which was
given to this deployment by us
here is namespace where such deployment
was created default namespace
below you'll see that kubernetes
automatically assigned labels to this
particular deployment and there was just
single label up equal assign nginx
deployment also there are annotations
again created automatically here is
annotation and here is also selector
selectors are used in order to connect
ports with deployments because in
kubernetes ports and deployments are
actually separate objects and we have to
know how to assign specific ports to
particular deployments
and here we see selector up equal sign
nginx deployment
and for a particular port which was
automatically created and assigned to
this deployment we will find a label
with the same value up equal sign nginx
deployment we will have a look at that
just in a minute
also there is replicas field
and here you could find information
about quantity of the pods which are
desired by this deployment
and the actual quantity of the ports
which are running
here is just single port single replica
which is desired one updated one total
and one available it means that now
there is
one port which is assigned to this
deployment
here is also strategy type rolling
update which tells how to perform
updates of the deployments we will get
back to it a bit later in this course
and also below you'll find other details
about this particular deployment
here you'll find also details about port
template and as i just told you you'll
find out inside of the port
corresponding label up equal sign nginx
deployment
and same label is mentioned here in the
selector field in the deployment
and that's how deployment is connected
to particular ports
also if you scroll a bit down you'll
find
actual events related to this particular
deployment and here we see single event
scaling replica set
but what is replica set
a bit above you see new replica set
nginx deployment and id of the replica
set
and replica set actually manages all
ports related to deployment
and replica set is a set of replicas of
your application because you could
create 5 10 100 different ports in the
same deployment and all of them are
included in the replica set
and that's why here you see that such
replica set was scaled up
to one and one port was created in this
replica set
great these are details about this
particular deployment and now let's have
a look again at the list of the pods k
get pods
here is just single port and notice its
name
it starts with the name of the replica
set which we just discussed and saw in
the output of the details of the
deployment nginx deployment and this
hash
and afterwards there was specific hash
for this particular report
and if there are multiple ports in the
same deployment which belong to the same
replica set
you'll see same prefix here
but different hashes here for different
ports
now there is just single port which is
ready and which is running also we could
get details about this particular pot
let's grab its name
and enter here k describe
port and here let's paste copied hash
and here are details about this
particular report let's scroll up
here is name of the port it matches with
this name
it was assigned to default namespace
same as deployment
here is note where this particular
port is running right now
here are labels of this particular port
and i see such label as up nginx
deployment and port template hash
notice that this hash is equal to this
hash and it matches with id of the
replica set
also i see status running here is ip
address of the port and here i see that
it is controlled by specific replica set
replica set nginx deployment and heroes
hash of the replica set which controls
this particular pot
also here are details about containers
which are running inside of the port and
here is container id and image which was
used for creation of the container in
this particular port
also at the end you could find the logs
related to the port as we discussed
before successfully assigned to specific
node pulling image nginx and so on
now there is deployment
and instead of the deployment there is
replica set
and ports are managed by this deployment
now there is just single pot
great now let's try to scale this
deployment and increase quantity of the
ports inside of the deployment now there
is just single port
for that we could utilize following
command cube ctl shortly k in our case
scale
we would like to scale deployment let's
write here deployment
name of the deployment in our case is
nginx-deployment
and afterwards let's specify quantity of
the replicas we would like to have in
this deployment right now
now there is just single replica
in order to specify desired quantity of
the replicas we could add here option
replicas and after equal sign specify
quantity of the replicas let's say we
want to scale to 5 replicas let's enter
5 here and let's scale our deployment
deployment was scaled and now let's
enter command k get bots
and i see that there are four new
containers which are currently being
created
here is one put
second third and fourth port and this
port is still running
in a moment you should see that all five
ports will be running here they are
we just scaled our deployment to five
different replicas and now there are
five different pots running right now
inside of our kubernetes cluster
and notice how easy it is
we did not create those poles manually
kubernetes scaled this deployment
automatically for us
notice that all those spots have the
same prefix it is name of the replica
set all those spots belong to
and those parts are different for
different pots
and again all pots are running
let's also read details about those
spots which will include ip addresses
let's add here option dash o white
and i'll see that each port has
different ip address here here here here
or here
and all those ports were created just on
single node mini cube because again we
have just single node cluster
if you were running multiple nodes of
course load would be distributed across
different nodes and you would see that
ports were assigned to different nodes
all right now let's try to scale down
quantity of the replicas in this
deployment
from five to let's say three let's go
back to this command k scale deployment
nginx deployment and here let's specify
quantity of the replicas s3 like that
deployment was scaled let's get pods and
i see that now there are only three
ports up and running
two ports were
removed
great now let's try to connect to one of
the ports for instance this one let's
grab its ip address and before we
already tried to connect to one of the
ports from our local computer and again
our local computer is external relative
to kubernetes cluster it is very very
important
let's try to connect to this ap address
c url and paste ap address and
connection is not successful
let's now go inside of the node mini
cube node and try to connect to this
port any of those ports from inside of
the node
and it will mean that we are trying to
connect to the port inside of the
cluster
let's ssh again to our mini cube
node
ssh docker
at
and this ap address
in your case this ip is of course
different
password is tc user
and now here let's see url and enter ip
address of one of the ports any port
works here
so let's see url and i was able to
connect to specific port by its ip
address
let's try to connect to another port
with another ip for instance let's try
0.3 i'm not sure whether i have such pod
running yes i have and i also got
response from such port with such ip
address recap that now i am located
inside of the node and i am able to
connect two ports which are running on
this specific node using ip addresses of
those ports let's exit from this node
and again let's list ports along with ap
addresses so i was able to connect to
this port and this port from the node
but of course such ap addresses are
assigned to ports dynamically when new
ports are created
and you should not rely on ip addresses
of the ports if you would like to
connect to specific port
therefore it's not convenient to utilize
such ap addresses and you should utilize
some sort of other ip addresses
which are managed by kubernetes and
which allow you to connect to any of the
ports inside of the deployment
let me show you how to do that
in kubernetes you have to create
so-called services if you would like to
connect to specific deployments using
specific ip addresses
and there are different options
available you could create so-called
cluster iep and such ap address will be
created and assigned to specific
deployment
and you will be able to connect to this
specific deployment only inside of the
cluster using this virtual ap address
and kubernetes will distribute a lot
across different ports which are
assigned to specific deployment
but please note that such ap address
will be just single ip address for
entire deployment
and of course it is much more convenient
to use such ep address than specific ip
addresses of the ports as we just tried
also there is an option to create
external ip addresses to open deployment
to outside world
and it is possible to expose specific
deployment to the ip address of the node
or
use load balancer
recap that
inside of the kubernetes cluster it is
possible to have multiple nodes and
ports could be distributed across
different nodes
therefore the most common solution is to
have load balancer ap address which will
be just single for entire kubernetes
cluster for specific deployment
and you will be able to connect to your
deployment no matter where our ports are
created
using just single external ip address
but such load balancer ip addresses are
usually assigned by specific cloud
provider like amazon web services or
google cloud
and such assignments are managed by
cloud controller manager it is service
which is running on the master node
let's now try to create cluster iep for
our deployment and we will create for
that specific service
so we already have deployment created
let's read details about size deployment
k
get deployments
by the way you could shorten such long
road just to deploy like that k get
deploy
and here is name of our deployment now
there are three different ports which
are ready in this deployment let's now
create a service for this particular
deployment and using service you could
expose specific port from the deployment
now we are running three different ports
and inside of each port there is nginx
container
and by default nginx web server is
running at port 80.
it means that we have to expose internal
port 80 from the containers
to any other port outside of the
deployment
and we could choose for instance prot
8080 for this particular example
in order to expose internal port from
the deployment ports
you should utilize command expose
let's enter k
expose deployment
here will be name of the deployment we
would like to create a service for
nginx deployment
here is the name of our deployment
recap that we don't mention here ports
we work with deployments
and ports are managed by deployments
so let's expose deployment nginx
deployment here will be option port
let's specify a port which we would like
to utilize as external port for our
deployment and let's set it to port 8080
and also we have to add here a target
port
if port inside of the containers is
different from this product which we
specify right now here
and in our example right now port inside
of the container is 80. that's why we
have to add here option
target
port
equal sign 80.
so we expose internal port from the
containers
to external port 8080 and we do that for
the deployment here is name of the
deployment
all right let's expose nginx deployment
service nginx deployment was exposed
and now let's list services for that
there is command k get
services and now there are two services
first service is default system service
it is called kubernetes type is cluster
ip and here is cluster ap address
and also here we see one more service
nginx deployment
here is name here is type cluster ip and
here is cluster iep
and this ip address is completely
different from the ap addresses assigned
to the pods
this ap address is even from another
network
ip addresses of the ports start from 172
and here this ip address starts from 10
and this is a virtual ip address
which was created by kubernetes
and it is just single ip address
which could be used in order to connect
to any of the ports
and such type cluster ip allows you to
connect to specific deployment in our
example nginx deployment
only from inside of the kubernetes
cluster for instance if in your
kubernetes cluster there is database
deployment for instance there is mongodb
database or mysql database and such
database should not be available and
accessible from outside world
you could create cluster ap service for
such database deployment
and other deployments inside of your
kubernetes cluster will be able to
connect to database deployment using
cluster ip but again such deployment
will be hidden from the outside world
but on other hand if you create any web
service deployment and it should be
available from outside of course you
have to expose it to outside world using
node port or load balancer that's what
we'll try a bit later
cluster ip will be available only inside
of the cluster
so here we see cluster ip address here
it is
and here is port which was exposed
by our deployment
also you could get list of services
using short version of this command
simply enter k get svc it is short
version of services svc
and result will be the same there are
now two different services with those
cluster ap address this one for
kubernetes service and this one for
nginx deployment service
and now let's try to connect to our
deployment using this service
let's grab this cluster app and let's
first try to connect to this cluster ip
address from our local computer
see url
and paste this ap address and after
calling let's also add port which we
exposed it is external port for our
deployment internally it will be proxy
to port 80 on each container let's try
whether this works on our local computer
or not see url and i see no response
that's what i just told you cluster ip
address is not available
outside of the kubernetes cluster
that's behavior of the cluster ip it's
just internally available ip address
but you are able to access cluster iep
from any node and let's try it
let's ssh to our
node let me go back to this command ssh
docker and ap address of the node dc
user
and let's now try to connect to cluster
ip from the node and here again let's
specify port 8080
and i see result welcome to nginx
and this response was provided by one of
the posts in the deployment
of course now from this output i am not
able to recognize which port exactly
answered me but this answer was provided
by one of the pods in the deployment
i could try again again again and i get
answer from the pods in the deployment
that's how it works
cluster ip is just single ip
which was created as a service for a
particular deployment and you could
utilize just single ip in order to
connect to any of the pots
and behind the scenes kubernetes does
all procsing of the request to
particular selected port and it balances
a lot across different ports in the
deployment
alright let's close this connection and
let's now also read details about
particular service
we kept that there is command k get svc
short version for get services and here
is name of the service which we created
before
let's take this name and right now k
describe
service
and name of the service we would like to
get details about
here is cluster ip which we just used in
order to connect to this service
also there is external port and here is
target port and here are three different
endpoints
those endpoints indicate particular
ports
which are used for connections to this
particular cluster ip
so load will be balanced across those
three different ports
and notice everywhere here port 80 it is
target port for our service the sport
80. this default port where nginx server
is running
so 80 80 and 80.
also here you see type of the service
cluster ip and selector here is also
present up equal sign nginx deployment
and that's how this service is actually
connected to particular ports
all those spots also have particular
label up nginx deployment
and this label was created by kubernetes
automatically we did not specify it
because we just created deployment using
create deployment command and we created
service using expose command
namespace here is default same as for
ports and deployment which is called
nginx deployment
alright
that's it for this service and we
exposed our deployment using cluster ipv
and cluster ip is only available inside
of the kubernetes cluster now you know
how to create a port how to create
deployment how to scale deployment and
how to create a service for particular
deployment
and we utilized
nginx image which is available at docker
hub
and now it's time to move on to the next
step in our plan and i promised you that
we will create custom docker image push
it to docker hub and afterwards create
deployment based on this image and
that's what we'll do next
but before doing that let's remove
existing service and deployment in order
to have clean let's say setup so let's
remove deployment
k delete deployment
and here will be name of the deployment
nginx deployment
and also let's delete service k delete
series
nginx
deployment
like that service was deleted as well
let's list now deployments k get
deployed it is short version of the
deployments no resources found and let's
list services k get svc
just single default service with name
kubernetes
we are good to go and now let's create
very basic node.js application there we
will utilize express web server package
and create our custom web server
plan for this next step is following
first we will create node.js express web
application and we will configure web
server in such a way that it will
respond with the host name of the server
when we connect to it using root url and
in such way we will be able to
distinguish which port actually answers
specific request
we will also dockerize such application
using a docker file and docker build
command
and afterwards push build docker image
to docker hub
and finally we will create deployment
using such customly built image
you could find all final project files
in the github repository you'll find
link to it right now here
but i highly recommend to you to create
such an application yourself even if you
don't know much about node.js and
express and of course i recommend to you
to build your custom image and push it
to your docker hub account of course you
could utilize images available under my
account they are public it's up to you
so let's now open visual studio code if
you don't have it please install it i'll
open it up
and here in the visual studio code
please open up embedded terminal press
key combination control backtick like
that
terminal was opened and now let's create
folder for our project files ilcd to
desktop
and here using make directory command
i'll create folder k8s
stands for kubernetes as you already
know let's cd to k8s folder and you
could open any folder
using code dot command if you correctly
installed visual studio code if such a
command is not available on your
computer you could press key combination
command shift
p or ctrl shift p on windows
and here enter
code and select shell command install
code command in path and afterwards code
command will be available from
any terminal so i have this command
already available in the path that's why
i'll open the k8s folder in the visual
studio code editor so code dot
it will be opened in the new window
like that
now this folder is completely empty and
has no files let me again open embedded
terminal here it will be opened in k8s
folder and now here let's create a
folder for our first project
and this folder name will be let's say
k8s
dash web
hello because we will build very basic
web application which will simply
respond hello from server and server
name so k8s web hello
and here in this folder we will create
node.js application
let's hear in the terminal cd2k8s
web hello folder like that
and here first we will initialize
node.js application and in order to do
so you have to install npm on your
computer if you don't have node.js and
npm available please
go to node.js download
here is link download node.js and
install node.js on your computer it will
be installed along with npm
of course we will not run application
using node.js on our computers
we will run application inside of the
container in the kubernetes cluster
instead
but in order to initialize project
locally and install dependencies you
have to use npm so therefore please
install node.js along with npm
afterwards npm should become available
on your computer i'll hide this back
pane
and now here let me npm init and i'll
initialize this project and you could
add here option dash y which will skip
all answers to you during initialization
of the new node.js project so npm init y
new project was initialized and here you
should find now package.json file with
such contents
name of the project version and so on
and now let's install package called
express
npm install
express
it will be downloaded from the npm
registry
package was installed and packaged the
json file was updated here is now
dependency called express
so now let's create the
index.js file in our k8s web hello
folder by the way notice that now there
is node modules folder which contains
all dependencies of our project but now
it is safe to simply remove this folder
we don't need it anymore because we will
not run this project locally with help
of node so simply select this folder and
delete
all right now we have only package the
json and package log.json files great
now let's create file and we will create
it inside of the k8s web hello folder so
new file and let's name it index
dot mjs
why m because we will utilize es6
modules syntax which is available in
node.js starting from version 13 and if
you would like to use import statements
instead of the required statements you
have to name files with extension mgs so
let's create file index.mgs
and here i will not type contents of
entire application i will simply copy
them in order to save some time
so paste here
if you would like you could of course
write this very tiny application
yourself so we import express from
express package we also import os from
os os is built in node.js module and
afterwards we create express application
here is port
3000 you could specify any other port if
you would like and that's that port
where our express web server will be
running inside of the container
here we are adding a route handler for
slash url it is root url and we simply
answer to the client with text hello
from the os host name using os package
we retrieve hostname of the server
and
in the response from the server you will
see simply text message hello from the
end name of the server where this
application is running
so rest sent we send to the client such
message and also we log it to the
console
and finally we start express web server
update listen and we started at this
port 3000 and when server starts we will
look to the console message web server
is listening at prod and hero sport
i will not dive deeper into the
explanations and syntax of node.js
because it is not node.js course but you
get an idea we create very basic web
server which will respond with such text
message
so let's save changes in this file ctrl
s on windows or command s on mac like
that changes we are saved
and now let's dockerize this application
and for that we will create docker file
now i recommend to you to
install extensions called docker and
kubernetes
so go to extensions here and enter first
docker here
select docker and click install in my
case docker extension was already
installed and afterwards please also
install kubernetes extension find it
like that and install it as well in my
case kubernetes extension was installed
earlier so now we are good to go and
also in order to build actual docker
image
you have to run docker on your computer
before we did not launch docker in order
to start mini cube kubernetes cluster
but now we need docker in order to build
docker image
that's why please go ahead and install
docker if it is not installed on your
computer
enter docker download
go to this link
and install docker desktop which is
available for windows mac os and also
you could install docker directly on
linux like systems
so please go ahead and install docker
afterwards please run it i'll run it
like that i already installed it before
now here i see icon docker is starting
here i see information about that
i'll wait a bit meanwhile let's create
docker file inside of the k8s web hello
folder because we are creating now
separate application in the k8s root
folder so let's create docker file here
new file and name it
docker file like that
notice that visual studio code
recognized type of this file and it has
added the icon docker
and here in the docker file let's add
instructions how we would like to build
custom docker image
i'll again grab contents of this docker
file and paste here in order to save
some time
and there are following instructions
we will use node alpine as a base image
for our custom image
here we set working directory as
slash up next we expose port 3000
afterwards we copy two files
package.json and package dashlock.json
which are present here and then we run
npm install
when we will build this custom image
and after npm install we are copying all
remaining files from this folder where a
docker file is located in our example it
will be just single file index.mgs
and this file will be copied to the app
folder inside of the image
if you are not familiar with those steps
and don't know what from work your
expose and so on mean i highly recommend
you to find the docker crash course and
go through it in order to understand how
docker works and how you are able to
build custom images this course is not a
docker course
so we copy all remaining application
files to target folder up and finally we
add instruction cmd that stands for
command
which actually indicates which command
will be executed when corresponding
container based on this custom rebuilt
image will be started
and we want to run npm start command
but what happens now if we enter npm
start in our project folder let's try it
let's save first changes in docker file
save and let's open up again embedded
terminal i am still in k8s web hello
folder and here in this folder there is
index.mgs file and here let's enter npm
start command
and what i see i see missing script
start
now our application will not launch
anything if you enter npm start command
in order to be able to run our
application start web server we need to
modify package
dot json file let's do that let's open
up package.json file and here you'll
find scripts section and there is just
single default script test
let's
actually replace test with start like
that and here in double quotes type
node index
dot mgs
so now there will be
start script
and it will essentially run using node
file
index.mgs
and this will start actually our express
web server on the port 3000
that's what we discussed here
let's save changes in package.json file
now npm start is available
and we are able now to build
our image
if you want to create custom image you
need to utilize docker build command
and usually this command is entered in
the folder where docker file is located
that's this folder in our example here
and if i list files and folders here
i'll find docker file
and dockerfile contents are here
from workdir expose and so on till cmd
now let's build docker image and also we
will add tag to this customly built
docker image
and tag will include also username
of your account at dockerhub
if you don't have dockerhub account
please go to hub.docker.com
and create account
i already have account and here is my
username
please create your account and choose
your username and afterwards you will be
able to push repositories to docker hub
under your account
and when you push repositories you will
find them here in the repositories
section
now under my account there are no
repositories in this namespace
so let's go back to visual studio code
and here let's build custom image for
our application
let's use command docker
build
next will be path to docker file i'll
use simply dot because now i'm inside of
the folder where docker file was created
so docker build dot
next let's add tag to our image using t
option
then will be user name of your github
account in my case i'll type mine
and after slash i'll give name to the
repository
let's name it same as we named this
folder
k8s
dash web hello like that
let's build this image using docker
build
command building image
notice that in my case
base image was already present in the
cache and
other layers were also cached and
finally image was built now if i enter
command
docker images and add grep
and here will be k8s
web
i'll find image that is now available in
our local images repository
here is name of the image which we just
built
tech is latest because in this command
which i just entered i did not specify a
tag which you are able to specify after
column here but i build image with later
stack so that's why tech here is latest
and
here is the id of the build image and
size of the image
now let's push this custom rebuild image
to docker hub
in order to do so you have to first
login to docker hub for that please
enter command docker login
i already logged in before that's why
docker utilized cached credentials and
login succeeded in your case if you
enter docker login for the first time
you will be prompted to enter docker hub
login and password
now i am able to push this build image
to docker hub
for that i'll utilize command docker
push and here will be name of the image
which i would like to push to remote
repository hosting service
vista shoot k8s web hello
let's go ahead and push it
using default tag latest
pushing different layers of the image
it takes some time because image is
relatively large
so you see waiting for those layers
and finally this image was pushed to
docker hub let me verify that it
appeared here
refresh page and now there is k8s web
hello image
wonderful
this image by the way is public and you
are able to utilize it as well for your
kubernetes deployments
image is ready and available at docker
hub and now we are able to create a
kubernetes deployment based on this
image
let's do that let's go to terminal here
and let's create new deployment by the
way now there are no deployments k get
deploy
no deployments k
get svc services no services just single
one kubernetes it is default one and now
let's create new deployment based on
customly built image for that let's
first utilize same command as we used
before okay create deployment okay
create deployment
let's name it k8 s
web
hello
and the next will be option image
and image will be vista shook in my case
slash k8s web hello
same name as
it appears here when i pushed this
image to the docker hub
and the same name as i see here
so here is my username and heroes name
of the docker repository
let's go ahead and create deployment
based on this image
of course if you performed all steps
yourself and pushed customly built image
to docker hub under your account you
could utilize here your username
so let's go ahead and create new
deployment
deployment was created let's
k get pods
now i see that container creating status
is status of this spot which was created
for this deployment let's check again
still container creating because it
takes some time to pull image from
docker hub
and now i see that container is running
great
here is name of the container and here
is hash of the replica set which was
created by deployment and here is
specific hash for this particular port
now let's create service
using cluster ip and try to connect
afterwards to our web server which is
running using
node.js express
so let's create service for that we will
expose port k expose
deployment
hero will be name of the deployment k8s
web
hello next let's add option port and
recap that our express web server is
running at port 3000. let's go back to
our application go to index.mgs file and
here is this prod 3000 and we could
basically expose it to the same external
port that will be used for connections
to deployment
let's utilize for that just single port
we will not need for that target port
option that's why let's add dash
dashboard equal sign 3000 like that
and this will create cluster ip for
deployment k8s web hello
let's go ahead and create service let's
list services k get svc
and here is newly created service here
is name of the service and here is
cluster ip which was created by
kubernetes
and again using such ap address we will
be able to connect to our deployment it
means that you could connect to any of
the pods you don't select which port you
will be connected to kubernetes does
this job for you
and here we see that we opened port 3000
exposed port 3000 let's try to connect
to this cluster ip and port 3000 let me
copy this cluster ip and of course i
will not be able to connect to this
cluster ap from my local computer that's
why let's as usually quickly connect to
our mini cube node
ssh
docker at this iep
59 101 in your case this ip is different
here our password is tc user
and now here let's see url
to cluster ip and port 3000 that's that
port which we exposed from deployment
so
let's go ahead and i see message hello
from the k8s web hello and entire name
of the server where
express node.js application is actually
running
and that's that message which comes from
the express web server here
that's where we send it back to the
client hello from the and name hostname
of the server where this application is
running
and it means that everything works
perfectly
we created deployment based on the
customly built image which we pushed to
docker hub
and here a result of it and we see
response from the web server application
wonderful by the way if you enter a curl
command like that you will not be
automatically moved to the new prompt
and you will stay on this line if you
want to move to the new line you could
enter a c url then add the semicolon and
add here echo like that
and now you will be moved to the new
line here in the output wonderful now we
got response from the same port here we
see same hostname as we saw here
now let's keep this
window open here
and let's increase quantity of the ports
in our deployment let's scale our
deployment
i'll open up new tab in the item
application you could open new terminal
window if you're on windows i'll use key
combination command t in order to open
new tab here and here in the new tab if
i enter k i will say error command not
found because alias works only in this
tab that's why let's create alias once
again alias k
equal sign cube ctl by the way you could
omit double quotes here if a command
consists only of single word so let me
remove those double quotes like that
alias was created and now let's k get
pods
and here i see same name of the pod
which i saw here in the answer from the
web server
let's now scale this deployment recap
that name of our deployment is
k8s web hello here is name of the
deployment and now it currently has just
a single pod
let's scale it
k
scale deployment
k8s web hello and i would like to scale
deployment to let's say for replicas
let's go ahead deployment was scaled
let's now get pods k get pods
now there are four ports one is still
being created
let's check back again and now all four
ports are running
all of them belong to the same
deployment k8s web hello and each port
of course has its own unique ip address
let's get details about pods k get ports
dash or white
and here i see different ip addresses of
each pot
and of course they differ from the
cluster ip which was created for
specific service
let's list services k get svc
and here as before we see cluster ip for
k8s web hello service
and each of those spots
is now available via this cluster ip and
kubernetes will decide which port to
choose for each particular request
let's now go back to this step where we
are inside of the kubernetes node
and try to make connections to this
cluster ip and this port again
let's clear terminal here and see url
now i see response from this port with
such name if i repeat command i see
response from other port
let's repeat command once again
once again
and so on i see that now load is
balanced across different ports because
here i see responses from different
ports
different names appear here in responses
different ports serve different requests
and here are different names of the pods
that's how distribution of the load
works in action and now using such
customly built docker image we were able
to prove that all right let's continue
and now let's modify type of the service
which we create for our deployment
because now there is cluster ip which is
available only from inside of the
cluster
let's go here and
let's delete the current service k8s web
hello simply take its name
let's clear terminal and enter k delete
svc stands for service and paste name of
the service we would like to delete
service was deleted k get svc there is
no such service anymore and if i try to
connect again to deployment using
cluster ip which we used before i'll
definitely get an error
so i see no response
great
let's now create service again but now
we will set its type to node port
let's use same command k expose
deployment
k8s web hello
and here will be type
which will be set to node port
in pascal case notation node port and
let's add here port option and prot will
be set to 3000 same port as we utilized
before it is that part where our
containers actually run express node.js
application let's go ahead and create
such service of type node port
deployment was exposed let's list
services get svc
and now there is again service with name
k8s web hello its type now is node port
here is again cluster ip
and port
but here i see port which was specified
here using port option and also after
column i see randomly created port
32142
and now i am able to connect to
deployment
using node ip address
i could get node ap address by entering
mini cube ip
we have only single node recap and here
is its iep in my case and i could take
this ip
add this port
and i will connect to one of the ports
in this deployment
let's do that let me grab this ip go to
web browser for example
because now i will be able to connect to
deployment from my computer let me paste
this ip and after column i will add this
port
like that
so in my case connection string is here
so here is ap address it is ip address
of the node and here is randomly
generated port which was created by
kubernetes itself when we created
service for our
deployment let's go ahead and try to
connect
and i see response from one of the pods
let's refresh
and i see response from other pot with
other name
refresh again and i see response from
other port here
that's how we are able to connect to our
deployment using node port service
also it is more simple way to get url
for connection to this deployment by
using minicube service command minicube
service and here type name of the
service in our case k8s web
hello
let's enter and new
tab in the web browser will be opened
automatically and notice url here same
as i just used before ip address of the
node and port which was automatically
generated by kubernetes
that's node port type of the service
also here you could
see this actual url when you enter mini
cube service k8s web hello here is
actual url and if you want to get only
url you could add here option
url
and you'll see only url and you could
grab it and paste it anywhere you want
so that's node port service type
and it exposed
deployment at the port of the node and
here is this specific port in my example
in your case this port will be
completely different
and the one more option which i would
like to show you in terms of creation of
the service is load balancer let's
create a load balancer service and for
that first let's delete existing service
k delete
svc service k8s web hello
service was removed okay get svc there
is no more such service and let's create
a service of type load balancer
okay expose
deployment
k8s web hello
here let's add type
load balancer
pascal case notation again and let's add
port option and its value will be 3 000
same as before
let's create such service service was
created k get svc
now i see that there is service of type
load balancer here is cluster ip but
external ip here is pending and you will
see here pending if you are using mini
cube
but when you deploy your applications
somewhere in the cloud using one of the
cloud providers like amazon google cloud
etc here you will see load balancer ip
address assigned automatically
but in our case using minicube its
behavior is similar to node port and
here we will still be able to connect to
our deployment using ip address of the
node and if i enter now mini cube
service
k8s web hello
i'll see connection which is made to ip
address of the node and here is again
random port which was generated here
here is this random port all right let's
continue and let's keep this service and
this deployment in place recap that we
have single service here which we
created before it is k8s web hello and
this type now is load balancer and there
is single deployment okay get deploy
and this name is k8s web hello and now
this deployment has four different ports
available for use
we could read details about this
deployment k
describe
deployment
k8s web hello
and here are details of this deployment
by the way at the end here i see logs
related to scaling of replica set
initially quantity of the replicas was 1
and later we scaled it to 4. if you want
you could try to scale it to any other
number if you want to do so
above i see that this deployment has
name k8s web hello namespace is default
labels annotations selector replicas
desired for updated for available form
and now let's try following let's try to
update
version of the image
in our deployment
notice here
that strategy type is rolling update
what does it mean
when you release new version of your
application
of course you want to roll out this new
version in production smoothly without
any interruption of service and
kubernetes allows that out of the box
and this is very easy
and
this strategy type rolling update
means that
new ports
will be created with new image while
previous spots will be still running
so ports will be replaced
one by one and finally in some time all
posts will be running new updated image
and now let's try that in action
we will update a bit our application and
build new image with another tag for
instance version 2.0.0
and afterwards we will modify image in
our deployment and see what will happen
how kubernetes will roll out this update
so let's go ahead and do that
by the way i don't need this step
anymore
where i created ssh connection to node
therefore let me exit from this
connection and close this step actually
and i'll keep only one tab opened
so
let's go back to visual studio code and
here are contents of the index.mgs file
and we already have image available for
this version of the application
where server answers us with such string
now let's modify this string for
instance let's add here prefix version 2
like that
and let's now build new image with new
tag push it to docker hub and afterwards
modify image in our deployment
let's save changes in this file open up
embedded terminal and let's build image
and assign another tag to it
now image has only single tag it is
latest so let's build new image
docker build
dot
t tag vista shoot
prepend your name if you want to push
this
version of the image to your docker hub
account so vista shook and here will be
name of the image k8s web hello and
after column i'll add the tag for
instance
2.0.0 like that
let's build a such image recap that i
modified index.mgs file and i updated
this string
so it should build new image
let's go ahead and build it
building
exporting layers image was built and now
let's push it to docker hub i'll copy
this
name including tag
and now here i enter docker push
and new version of my application will
be pushed using separate tag for the
same k8s web hello image so let's go
ahead and push
pushing
i see that some layers already exist and
only one layer was pushed
so image was pushed successfully let me
verify that
go to my
docker hub account refresh
i still see just a single image here it
is let me click on it
and here i should find two texts latest
and
2.0.0
now let's deploy this new version of
this image and for that we will utilize
following command let's go to the
terminal here and let's set new image
for the deployment okay set image we are
setting new image for particular
deployment next will be deployment
name of the deployment k8s web
hello and afterwards we need to select
ports where we would like to set new
image
here we will write
k8s web hello
and after equal sign we will specify new
image in my case it is b stachook
slash k8s web hello
column 2.0.0
that's new tag which was assigned by us
before we push the new version of the
image to docker hub
after entering this command image will
be changed and rollout update will be
started
be ready to enter following command
after this one
k rollout status deployment k8s web
hello you could prepare this command
somewhere in the text editor and
afterwards quickly paste it after this
command i'll try to enter it manually
let's go ahead and change image image
updated k rollout
status
deployment
k8s web hello
waiting for deployment allowed to finish
and now i see the deployment
successfully rolled out
and before i saw such messages as
three out of four new replicas have been
updated
one old replicas are appending
termination and so on finally all
previous replicas were terminated
and new replicas were rolled out
let's now list pods k get pods
and now i see that there are four parts
and notice each of those spots
from 30 to 40 seconds
it means that previous spots were
fully terminated
and new pots were created and now in all
those four ports we are running new
version of our application
and we could verify that very easily by
accessing
our deployment using service there is
still service k get
svc type of kit is a load balancer and
here is cluster iep here with sport and
by entering command mini cube service
k8s web hello i could open connection to
one of the running ports so let's go
ahead
connection was opened and now i see
response which includes version 2.
that's how rolling updates work you
could refresh page here and you should
see response from other server for
instance this one
and again here i see version two it
means that our new application version
was successfully deployed to all ports
in the deployment
wonderful that's where rolling updates
and that's how you could check status of
the rolling update by entering command
k rollout status
this one if you would like you could
create one more tag for your image push
it to docker hub and verify how allow it
works again or if you want you could
roll back to previous version by the way
we could quickly try that together let's
go to this command and here i will
remove tag and it will mean that i would
like to utilize latest stack and let's
check how image will be modified again
and we are actually going back to
previous version of our application
let's modify image
let's check
allow status
two out of four new replicas have been
updated
waiting for deployment allowed to finish
and finally deployment successfully
rolled out and again i will see
four completely new ports okay get pots
here is age of those four ports
let's connect to our deployment again
mini cube service k8s web hello
and i again see hello from the server
without version 2.
that's where rolling updates wonderful
now let's try following now we have four
ports up and running but what happens if
i simply delete one of the ports
manually
let's try it
let's take for example this name of the
pod
notice each of those four ports
and enter k delete
port and paste name of any port you like
and after this command
let's
k get post again and i will see that new
port
will be created automatically container
creating
because we told kubernetes that desired
quantity of the pods in the deployment
is for
that's why it tries to do all its best
to create desired quantity of the
replicas in specific deployment and now
i will see that there are four ports
again up and running and age of this
spot is 33 seconds
all right we tried rolling updates and
also we tried to delete one of the
running ports and now let me demonstrate
you how to launch kubernetes dashboard
if you are using mini cube it is very
easy just single command
but if you are running kubernetes on
your own premises or somewhere in the
cloud it could be a bit more difficult
because you need to secure web access to
dashboard but here again it's just a
single command minicube
dashboard
like that let's enable dashboard
launching proxy verifying proxy health
and dashboard
web page will be opened here
and as you saw here
no prompt for username and password this
dashboard was simply launched like that
because we are using
mini cube
and here you could observe details about
your kubernetes cluster for example you
could go to deployments and you will
find single deployment here it is let me
decrease a bit font size like that so
here is metadata for this deployment
here are labels
strategy rolling update that's what we
observed
both status for available for updated
here are conditions
new replica set here is id of the
replica set which was created by this
deployment you could click on this
hyperlink and read details about
specific replica set
notice that
replica set deployment and ports all
belong to the same namespace default but
of course you could assign deployments
to different custom namespaces
labels for this replica set port status
for running for desired and here are
links to all ports which belong to this
particular replica set
also below there is service which was
created for this replica set for this
deployment type is load balancer here
and if you click on specific port you
could read details about particular port
heroes name of the port namespace when
port was created here is information
about the node where this port was
created status is running ip address of
the port below you could also find
details about replica set which actually
controls this particular port
and notice that label for this port is
here up column k8 s web hello and the
same label is found here controlled by
replica set and heroes label in the
replica set
also below you might find details about
events which happened in this particular
port for example here is a
step pulling image vista shoe k8s web
hello
and here are details about containers
which are now running inside of the pot
there is now just single container
inside of each pot
by the way if i go to replica sets i
will find actually two different replica
sets which were created for different
images for this image and for this image
and now in this replica set there are
zero pods
because we rolled back from this image
to this image with tag latest that's why
now here i see four ports and here are
zero pods
alright this graphical user interface
you could click on other menu items and
observe which for example nodes belong
to the cluster now there was just single
mini cube node
and if you click on it you could read
details about this particular node
that was kubernetes dashboard and you
could utilize it in order to observe
status of the kubernetes deployments and
services and so on
let me close it and now let's continue
and let's control c in order to
interrupt this process here and now
minicube dashboard will not be available
anymore
now important notice we just used
imperative approach
to creation of the deployments and
services
and we create deployments and services
using different cubectl commands
but usually that's not the way how
deployments and services are created
and in most cases declarative approach
is utilized
and in declarative approach you have to
create yaml configuration files which
describe all details for deployments and
services and afterwards apply those
configuration files using cube ctl apply
command
and that's actually declarative approach
of creation of different resources and
objects in kubernetes and that's what we
will do right now
let's now delete both deployment and
service which we created before and for
that you could utilize command cube ctl
delete deployment and afterwards delete
service but there is also short version
of deletion of all resources in default
namespace and it is k delete all
with option
o like that
all resources will be deleted
you see that ports were deleted service
was deleted and the deployment was
deleted as well
let's
get pods
ports are still being terminated let's
check again
still terminating
let's wait a bit
and now there are no resources found in
default namespace all pods were
terminated let's get services k get svc
and now there is only single default
system service kubernetes and of course
there are no deployments okay get deploy
no resources found
now let's create a yaml configuration
file
for deployment and for service first we
will create two separate configuration
files
let's go to visual studio code and here
let me by the way hide embedded terminal
for the moment and let me close those
all
windows
and now here let's collapse this folder
k8s web hello because this folder was
dedicated to our node.js express web
application and now here in the root of
the k8s folder here
let's create following files
deployment
dot yaml and also let's create file
service dot yaml
like that
so two files deployment.yaml and
service.yaml
let's first fill in deployment.iamo file
if you installed kubernetes extension
here in vs code what i asked you to do
before
you could create such configuration
files very fast
let me show you so type here simply
deployment
and you will see suggestion kubernetes
deployment
let's select it
and you will see that yaml configuration
file will be created automatically for
you
and you will see that
all appearances of the my app
will be highlighted and you could simply
type name of the deployment which you
would like to set and let's set name to
k8s
same as we did before but now we are
using yaml configuration file so k8s web
hello like that
deployment
name was set here is actual name for
this deployment here is api version apps
slash v1
here is selector with match labels key
and by this match label scheme we
specify which pos will be managed by
this deployment
and below there is nested template and
this template describes actually put
but here you don't need to specify
kind of the template like that because
this nested template for deployment
template is always spot therefore
kind here is not needed
next for
the ports which belong to this
deployment here we set labels and label
here is the same as label here in
selector match labels so this label and
this label match here
and next in spec key we specify which
containers we want to create in this
port
and there is just single container with
such name image is to be filled
we will replace this image placeholder
now with real image
and also below you could specify which
ports you would like to open in specific
container and below in the ports section
you could specify list of the container
ports which will be open on the ip
address
so let's fill now details in this spec
section
image will be vista shook
slash
k8s web hello
and the ports here will be containing a
port 3000
like that
also notice that
vs code kubernetes extension added
resources section here
and in this section there is limits key
which specify memory and cpu limits for
each port which will be created by this
deployment
and here we limit amount of memory and
amount of cpu resources
m means half of the cpu core
if you want you could modify 500 to 250
for example one fourth of the cpu core
let's keep it like that and that's it
for this specification of the deployment
let's save changes in this file and now
let me actually show how to find
documentation on how to create specific
yaml configuration files
let's go to web browser and here let's
go to kubernetes.io
and go here to documentation and here i
go to reference
and here i select kubernetes api
and in kubernetes api
you could select for example workload
resources
and you will find details how to
describe for example pods or create port
template or create replica set
just created deployment therefore let's
click on deployment section here
and you will find details how to create
yaml configuration files if you want to
create deployment api version must be
set to apps
v1 and below you will find other keys
which must be present in deployment
configuration file for example kind must
be set to deployment then there is
metadata section spec
status status by the way is filled by
kubernetes automatically and it will be
added after you create deployment based
on specific configuration file
and if i go back to configuration file
here i will find such keys as api
version kind metadata and spec
same keys which are described here api
version kind metadata and spec and if
you want to get details about deployment
spec you could click here
and you will find that inside of the
spec you have to specify selector
template replicas strategy mean ready
seconds and so on and if i have a look
at this pack here i will find out that
inside of spec in this example there is
selector and template selector and
template here
and both are required
if you click on template you will read
details about port template spec let's
click on it
and here you will find that inside of
the port template spec you have to
specify metadata and spec which is port
spec
and that's what we added here in the
template section metadata and spec for
the port let's click on port spec
and read details about port
specification containers is required and
you could add multiple containers in the
port specification if you want to do so
and here in this spec we have containers
here it is
let's click on container here
and in this container specification you
will find name which is required that's
why we set name as this
also you have to set image for specific
container
here with image resources and ports are
also described here on this
documentation page so here is pause
section
also you could set for instance
environment variables for a particular
container
i highly recommend to you to get
familiar with documentation and with all
options available and i just
demonstrated to you how you could dig
through documentation and find out how
to fill different sections of the
configuration file
all right we are done with creation of
the configuration file for deployment so
kind here is deployment
and let's now apply
this configuration file using
declarative approach creating such file
in place you will no longer require to
enter command cube ctl create deployment
you will just enter command cube ctl
apply
let's do that let's open up embedded
terminal here and now i'm still inside
of the k8s web hello folder let me go
out of this folder where this deployment
yaml file is located let's list files
here so here is deployment jammer
configuration file and here let's enter
command cube ctl
apply
dash f stands for file and here will be
name of the file deployment
dot yaml
simple as that
file was applied and deployment was
created let's check that
by the way here i don't have alias let's
add quickly alias alias k cube ctl
so k get deployments
and now there is k8s web hello
deployment
and there was a single port in this
deployment okay get pods
here is the spot which is up and running
great but how we could now scale
this deployment and increase quantity of
the replicas
very easily by modification of this
specification file
but here we could increase quantity of
the replicas
here at the moment we don't see any
numbers let's try to find out that using
documentation
i assume that i don't know how to change
that so let's go to workload resources
check deployment
and scroll down here so spec status
metadata kind
no options here let's click on
deployment spec
here is selector template replicas
number of desired ports
and that's that option which you need to
utilize if you want to modify quantity
of the replicas from default number one
so here is default number one to any
other number and you have to add
replicas key in the deployment spec so
let's go to deployment spec so here is
spec
and here
let's add new key replicas
and this value will be let's say number
five if i go back i could read that its
value is integer 32
so you don't need to write here a file
like that
right as a number
let's save changes
and let's apply this deployment yaml
configuration file again using same
command cube ctl apply f deployment
yammo let's go ahead
configured k get pods
and now i see that 4 new containers are
being created
and now
my deployment has
five different ports four of them are
already ready
now five are running
that's how we were able very easily
modify our deployment simply by
modification of the deployment yaml
configuration file
but of course now there are no services
k get svc
let's create new service
using similar approach
let's hide them by the terminal and
let's now go to service.yaml
configuration file and here let's also
speed up the process for creation of the
service configuration file and type
service and kubernetes extension will
offer us this option
and this spec will be created
automatically
kind is service api version is v1 here
it differs from api version for
deployment kind
metadata name sets name for this service
let's enter name k8s web hello
and also here let's modify selector
and selector will be up column k8s web
hello as well
by the way if you hover mouse over any
of the keys in this configuration file
you could find hyperlinks to
documentation for each particular key
for example key name url is here or if
you hover mouse over kind you could also
find hyperlinks here for api version for
kind and metadata for instance
all right what is left here in this
service is modification of the ports
section
here i see that port and target port
were auto populated
before we utilized we exposed actually
same port 3000 which is the port where
our express web server is running and
now we could try different port expose
port 3000 which is target port to put
let's say
30 30 like that
and it means that target port 3000 will
be exposed to external port 3030.
also notice that in this specification
there is no type for this service
and let's say that we want to create a
load balancer service
for that let's go to documentation
let's find documentation for service
here kubernetes api
service resources
service
and here let's click on service
specification
here we select reports and also below
you could find type of the service type
either cluster ip which is default or
external name or node port or load
balancer let's set type to load balancer
let's go back to our configuration file
and here in spec let's set type to load
balancer like that
that's it for this service specification
let's save changes in this file and
let's apply this
using same command as before cube ctl
apply
dash f stands for file and here type
service dot yaml i am still inside of
the k8s folder so let's apply service
yaml file
applied k get svc
and now i see that new service with type
load balancer was created
and now similarly as before i could open
connection to our deployment using
command mini cube service k8s web hello
let's go ahead
and page will be opened
refresh and i got response from another
pot
it means that now everything works as
before there is no service and
deployment and we created everything
using declarative approach using
configuration files
here is file for service and here is
file for deployment
we could also very easily delete
deployment and service which we just
created using just one command let's do
that go to the terminal and here enter k
delete
dash f
here will be name of the first file
deployment
yaml and here let's add dash f option
once again and type service.yaml
let's go ahead and delete both
deployment and service
let's check
k get svc
no service k get deployment
and no deployment
great now let's do following let's try
to create two deployments
and let's connect them with each other
because it's very common task when you
want to connect different applications
together for example connect front end
to back end or connect backend to
database service and so on
therefore now we will do following let
me draw a picture
so similarly as before we will create a
web deployment and
deploy there are our
nodejs express web application
and here let me type
web like that and also we will create
one more deployment
and we will name it
nginx
this nginx deployment will run
basic nginx image with no adjustments
and this nginx deployment will have
corresponding service with cluster ip
so let me draw here a line and here will
be
cluster ip
let's start with capital c cluster
ip like that
and
those two deployments of course are
located in the kubernetes cluster
and this deployment
will be also exposed but its service
will have type load balancer it means
that we will be able to connect to it
from outside using
load balancer's ip address so here is
load balancer
now inside of the web application we
will create two endpoints first will be
root endpoint same as before which will
return simply hello from the web server
and one more
endpoint here will be let's say nginx
and when connection will be made to
nginx
we will connect to nginx service by
using cluster iep
or you will see that
using nginx service name
like that so from one deployment we will
connect to another deployment
and get response from one of the ports
which will be running nginx application
and afterwards we will return back
result to the client with the contents
which we received from the engineering
export
so that's the plan
and in such way we will actually connect
to different deployments web deployment
and nginx deployment
let's get started with that here inside
of the k8s folder let me close those
files for the moment let's create a copy
of this folder k8s web hello which
contains all files related to our web
express application
let's copy this folder and paste here
and let's rename it simply click on this
name press enter and enter a new name
k8s web to
nginx like that
next
let's keep docker file unmodified
here are contents of this docker file in
this folder so no modifications here
but we will slightly modify
index.mgs file and i will grab modified
file from here let me copy it and paste
here
so here are contents of index.mgs file
for this second application
there is still root url here forward
slash
we still create express web server
but we add here one more endpoint nginx
and its route handler is now async
function because now we will connect to
another server simulating connection
between different deployments
and notice url here it is simply http
colon slash nginx
and we will create a service called
nginx for second nginx deployment
and from this deployment
we will be able to connect to another
deployment
using just name of the corresponding
service
simple as that
of course it is possible to connect
using either cluster ip but cluster ip
is dynamic
name of the service is static
so we will connect to one of the nginx
servers by using nginx service name
and here we utilize fetch which we
import from node fetch package by the
way in a moment we will install it in
this application as well
so we are waiting for response from the
nginx server
and afterwards we take body from the
response
calling text method
and simply return to the client
this body
essentially what this
endpoint will do it will simply proxy
request to the nginx server and return
result response from the nginx to the
client simple as that
and here we import fetch from node fetch
therefore we have to install such
external dependency
and for that let's open up embedded
terminal and here make sure that ucd to
this folder
k8s web to nginx
web to nginx
and here let's enter npm install
node page
installing package
you will see that this package the json
file will be modified
so now here are two dependencies express
and node fetch
dependency was installed and notice
again that node modules folder has
appeared here but we don't need it here
let's simply remove it
because inside of the
image which we will build right now we
have instruction to
run
npm install here it is that's why all
necessary dependencies will be installed
inside of the docker image
alright now we are good to go by the way
this application is also included in the
final project files which you could
clone from my github repository so
s web to ngnx and here is index.mgs file
and now let's uh again build a docker
image but it will be eu docker image
from this application
and now let's build it using same
command as before docker build
so let's list files and folders here
there is docker file docker file was not
modified it is the same as for previous
application and now let's build docker
image docker build dot and let's add tag
vista shook
slash and let's name it k8s web to nginx
same name as
for this folder
and let's keep tag as latest you don't
have to add here tag like that in this
case it will be added automatically so
let's build such image
image is been built notice npm install
command image was built and now let's
push it to docker hub let me grab this
name
docker push
and here will be name of the image which
i want to push to docker hub
pushing
some of the layers will be reused from
other image
and finally image was pushed and now we
are able to utilize it in kubernetes
deployment
great let's hide terminal and now let's
do following
now i would like to demonstrate you how
you could combine deployment yaml and
service yaml configuration files just in
one file
let's
close those files and let's create a new
file and let's name it
k8s
web to nginx
dot yaml like that
now in this configuration file we will
combine instructions for creation of the
deployment and service let's first go to
service.yaml take contents of this file
and paste here in the k8s web to nginx
yaml afterwards please add three dashes
exactly three and go to the next line
now let's go to yaml file for the
deployment let's take all its contents
and paste here under those three dashes
and now just in single file we have
specification both for service and
deployment
now let's modify deployment because we
would like to utilize other image and
here we will utilize other name
by the way we could select this name
here then right button click and
select change all occurrences and let's
name
service and deployment as k8s
web to nginx like that
let's keep type for this service as load
balancer
port here could be modified to another
for instance let's set it to all three
like that
and here in the deployment specification
let's decrease quantity of the replicas
to let's say three
and also let's modify specification for
containers
and the image which we would like to use
right now will be k8s web to nginx it
was replaced when i modified the k8s web
hello name
so here is correct image which we just
pushed to docker hub and this image we
would like to utilize for this
particular deployment
and container port will be unchanged
this 3000 all right that's it for
specification for deployment and service
for new application
and now let's create a specification for
nginx deployment and service because we
will deploy now two different
applications
one which will be based on our custom
image and second which is based on
official docker image called nginx
let's simply copy this file and paste
here and let's name
this file as nginx.yaml
and now in this
nginx.yaml file let's modify names
let's again select this and change all
occurrences and let's name it simply
nginx
please type exactly as i just did
exactly nginx
because this name for this service we
will utilize
inside of other deployment inside of our
containers which are running
express node.js web server we will
connect to this deployment by using
nginx service name
that's why this name is very important
here
now
we decided to utilize cluster ip service
type for this second deployment that's
why let's remove type load balancer from
here by default cluster ip will be
assigned here
and
let's modify ports section here let's
remove target port
and keep only port and set it to 80. it
is default port where nginx will run web
server
also in the deployment section we have
to modify image and now it will be
simply nginx without your username
because we would like to utilize default
nginx
image
let's keep resource limits here in place
and let's modify here container port to
80
like that
so quantity of the replicas will be for
instance 5 instead of 3. let's save
changes here and let's summarize what we
did here
we will create a new service called
nginx
and name here is important for our setup
here is the port section with single
keyboard and it means that external port
80 will be mapped to internal port 80.
it is port where nginx web server is
running by default
and the service type here is cluster ip
it means that such service
will not be available outside of the
kubernetes cluster
and here in this deployment we utilize
official docker image called nginx
here is specification for the port
containers and container port is set to
80.
that's it so we created
two yama configuration files nginx.yaml
and k8s web to nginx which utilizes
customly built image
here is this image name and now let's
apply both configuration files this one
and this one
let's go to the terminal and verify that
now we don't have any deployments k get
deploy
no deployments at the moment and no
services
and now let's deploy everything using
just single command
now i am still inside of the k8s web to
nginx folder let's go one level up where
our yaml configuration files are
located
here they are
this one and this one and let's apply
them k
apply dash f
here will be first file
here is its name and we could also apply
one more file dash f
nginx yamu
like that
let's go ahead and create both
deployments and both services
service created deployment created
service created and deployment created
let's check deployments k get deploy
there are no two deployments this one
and this one
partially they are ready okay get svc
let's read information about services
there are two services which were
created this one
which has type load balancer and nginx
which has type cluster ip recap that we
will connect from
this web to nginx deployment to nginx
deployment
using this name for the service
or we could also utilize cluster ipu in
order to connect from one deployment to
another but cluster ip is dynamic this
service name is static
so
let's also check pods k get pods
some of the pods are running and one is
still pending and now we are able to
test our setup and try to connect from
web application from web deployment to
nginx deployment
let's open connection to our web service
deployment because we
used here load balancer type for this
service
and we could utilize this port here
and ip address of the kubernetes node
recap that in order to quickly get url
for specific
deployment using mini cube you could
enter command mini cube
service and here will be name of the
service
k8s web 2 and jnx
web browser page was opened and we got
response from one of the ports which
belongs to k8s web to nginx deployment
and here is name of the corresponding
replica set
all right we just triggered connection
to root url
let's go back quickly to our application
let me hide this terminal here and let's
go to this new application and open
index.mgs file
and recap that here we have two
endpoints root endpoint and slash nginx
endpoint
which will essentially send request to
nginx url this one
and return back to the client proxy
response from other server this server
is external relative to this server
where we are running this web
application we just received this
string from the server let's now try to
connect to nginx endpoint let's go back
to our browser and add here
slash nginx
press enter and what i got
i got welcome to nginx
it means that the
response from the nginx
server
was proxied successfully
inside of the server which belongs to
our web deployment
and we were able in such way to connect
from one deployment to another
deployment
by the name of another service so nginx
here is name of another service as we
specified here
and such service has now cluster ip
okay get svc
so here is cluster ip for nginx service
and we were able to connect to another
deployment by name of the service
that's how you could very easily connect
different deployments together
and such resolution of the service name
to ip address is performed by internal
service of the kubernetes which is
called dns
and we could actually verify that
quickly let's go to the terminal for
example here
and recap that we could still get here
list of the pods k get pods
and now we could take any of the pods
and execute
any commands inside of the running
container inside of the port
using cubectl exact command this command
is very similar to docker exact command
let's now take name of any port which
belongs to k8s web to nginx deployment
let me copy this name in your case names
will be completely different
and let me clear a terminal here and
enter k exec here will be name of the
pot next will be two dashes
and afterwards let's type ns lookup
and jnx like that
let's press enter
and i got following response
what does it mean
using this command
we tried to resolve nginx name
from inside of the container which
belongs to this spot
and such resolution was successful
and this
ip address which i got
from the dns server
when i made request ns lookup nginx
but where does this ap come from
let's write k get svc
and here i get such iep and notice that
this iep is the same as this one
and that's what i told you
now kubernetes
is able to resolve name of the service
to corresponding cluster ip
and that's what we see here
and we performed resolution
inside of the port which belongs to
other deployment and other service
and of course i could execute similarly
command in one of the ports for example
i could type here we get
dash q o dash and here type http
and jnx
and this will actually connect to nginx
server and retrieve from it root web
page
let's try it
and i successfully received response
from one of the engineering spots
and here is nginx webpage
all right that's how different
deployments could be very easily
connected with each other let's go back
to visual studio code and let's delete
everything what we have so far
if you want to dive deeper and explore
details about those deployments you
could do that of course now you could
launch for instance minicube dashboard
you could dig deeper go to different
ports and explore what happens inside of
them and so on
you have all necessary knowledge for
that
alright now let's delete both
deployments and both services k delete
dash f
nginx dot yamo and dash f k8s web 2 and
jnx.yaml
let's go ahead
both services and deployments were
deleted okay get deployed
no resources found k get svc
just single service
i think you would agree with me that
deployment using yaml configuration
files is a much more pleasant and faster
than deployment using separate cube ctl
commands
we are done with main practical part of
this course and one step left and i
would like to demonstrate to you how to
change container runtime which is
currently darker in our kubernetes
cluster to other container runtime for
instance crio or container d
and in order to modify container runtime
we need to delete current mini cube
setup and create new one
for that let's go to the terminal here
and let's enter minicube status command
now it is running cubelet is running api
server is running
let's now stop minicube minicube stop
stopping node mini cube
one node was stopped and now let's
delete current setup mini cube delete
deleting mini cube in virtualbox in my
case
removed all traces of the mini cube
cluster
now let's create cluster over again
minicube
start
i will again use driver option
and its value will be virtual box in my
case if you are windows user you should
type here hyper v same as for previous
mini cube start
but please notice that the
docker option
did not work for me at least
i wasn't able to run cri all containers
inside of the docker container so for
some reason it didn't work therefore i
utilize virtualbox and i don't recommend
you to use now
driver docker so driver is virtualbox in
my case and next i will add option
container dash runtime
and this value will be cri dash o
one more option is container d
you could try both if you want to do so
so i will
enter here cryo like that and let's
create a mini cube cluster from the
scratch once again but now container run
time is set to crio
let's go ahead
start in control play node mini cube in
cluster mini cube again creating virtual
box
it will take a while
now i see step preparing kubernetes on
crio
and finally it was done let's now check
status mini cube
status
type control plane host is running
everything is running same as before but
now container runtime inside of the node
is crio let's check that
let's ssh to mini cube ip address and
let's enter here first mini cube ip
ssh docker at 192 168 59 102
yes
dc user
now i'm inside of the mini cube node and
now let's enter docker ps
and what i see i see cannot connect to
the docker
and it is an indication that docker is
not running inside of this node because
we are using cri o container runtime
instead
but how to check whether there are crio
containers
very easily using following command sudo
cri ctl ps
and here are a bunch of different
containers which are running
like two proxy core dns
storage provisioner and so on
now let's try again to deploy both
applications web application and nginx
application and create both services and
see how it goes
let's go back to visual studio code
and here let's perform same task as
before
simply apply configuration
k apply dash f and apply both yaml
configuration files let's go ahead
created deployments and created services
k get deploy
not ready yet but there are two
deployments
once again
again not ready let's get information
about services
there are two services same as before
k get posts
some of the posts are instead of
container creating one is pending
let's check again
some are already running
k get deploy
first deployment is ready nginx is not
yet ready
let's check again
now nginx is partially ready
and now all those containers were
created by cri all container runtime
let's enter a mini cube
service and name of this service
in order to test whether everything
works as before
so here is response from one of the pods
and let's add here slash nginx
and same as before it works
now we were able to proxy response from
the nginx deployment
wonderful
we just modified the container runtime
and now it is set to crio
let's go back to this ssh connection
where we connected to
node and here let's enter again sudo
cryctl ps and let's for example graph
by the name
k8s
web to nginx
and i see now three different containers
which belong to this deployment
and now they are running using crio
all right let's now disconnect from this
server
alright guys that's it for this
kubernetes for beginners course you
could of course keep your mini cube
cluster running you could create other
deployments you could build other docker
images in other words play with
kubernetes as you want and get familiar
with all kubernetes tools which we
discussed in this course
i hope you enjoyed this course and i
hope you enjoyed spending time with me
if so you could find me in the social
media networks all links you'll find
here on the screen and i will be more
than happy to meet you in other videos
and i wish you all the best bye bye
[Music]